le droit à l'avortement un débat qui
divise les états unis depuis des
décennies
la décision de la cour suprême
d'invalider roe contre wade presque
cinquante ans après son adoption ne fait
qu'intensifier la fracture entre les
deux camps
six des neuf juges affirment qu'il
n'existe aucune référence à l'avortement
dans la constitution américaine et
qu'aucune disposition ne sous-entend
qu'il s'agit d'un endroit protégé et à
revenir donc aux états de décider treize
d'entre eux s'étaient dotées d'une oie
gâchette ces lois adoptées pour entrer
en vigueur une fois gros contre wade
renversé interdisent ou restreignent
encore un peu plus l'accès à
l'avortement
devant le plus haut tribunal du pays les
réactions ont été vives
interdire l'avortement est illégitime
la maternité forcé est illégitime
des millions de vies seront sauvées
grâce à cette décision mais
pipeau avons avec le peuple a remporté
une victoire affirme le leader de la
minorité de la chambre le droit à la vie
et protéger les plus vulnérables ont
finalement une voix la décision a
enflammé la sénatrice du massachusetts
c'est une claque au visage des femmes
quant à leur droit d'user de leur propre
jugement et d'exercer un contrôle sur
leur propre corps affirme nancy pelosi
présidente de la chambre du mec ondes
ces jeunes le président des états unis
appelle les américains à voter
massivement aux élections de mi mandat
cet automne l'avortement les droits
individuels le droit à la vie privée et
à la liberté seront des enjeux
électoraux affirmé joe biden
pour régler la question une fois pour
toutes le président estime qu'il faudra
élire une majorité de politiciens qui
voudront en chasser le droit à
l'avortement dans une loi fédérale le
camp pro choix n'a pas dit son dernier
mot
ici valérie michaela bayne radio-canada
washington